[Music]
we will go over a lot of my games played
in las vegas 2010 and then after that
we're gonna do some nice studies okay
and game studies difficult ones but nice
so this game is I'm playing an
international master Eric Henson he is a
Grand Master now actually 2600
grandmasters so he's made a lot of
progress since last time we played so he
moved up about two hundred points and
became a GM so in this game he played
groom felt defense so as soon as he
plays d5 you know it's gonna be a
grünfeld defense if he plays Bishop g7
we have a Kings Indian defense so we
played here now I played this setup
Knight f3 Bishop g7 and I go Bishop to
g5 okay developing the bishop this is
not a very popular set up against the
ground foot but a very interesting one
so if you're looking into something not
very theoretical but very interesting
you can play this line so when I play
Bishop g5 the turret is pretty simple I
just want to take the knight and then
pick up the pawn take on f6 pick up the
pawn I just want to win a pawn now so he
has to play this active move 94 okay to
put pressure on my Bishop which pond
for who white black black which pond
take if you take you give up the center
c6 yeah you could but this is a slightly
worse position because this is just
white is just better because I have
active Bishop and when you play c6 you
cannot develop your night here okay so
you can get your night out now so 94 now
activating the night and putting
pressure on the bishop and now you could
play Bishop age four but I took and now
this is the line he takes my bishop
I take back
and now he plays here is six he's
pushing the pawn attacking here and also
attacking the knight on d5 okay so he
plays east six the knight is under
attack and he wants to take on d5 that's
what I did
that's right it quindi to protecting it
so that's what I did now Queen d2
protecting the night as mentioned she
has to take back now so he takes and now
look if I allow him to cancel my play
absolutely doesn't make sense because he
has two bishops - what do I have my only
thing
there are heavier is that I give him a
check so actually he loses his turn to
castle okay that's basically my
compensation for giving to bishops up
because if you move up here I will
exchange and pick up the pawn okay so if
you go here you just lose upon and
probably the game so if you go Bishop e6
then I take the King f8 is forced okay
but now what to do
he plays Queen f8 King f8 and he wants
to solidify his position here now and my
bishop is stuck on f1 so I play Queen f4
activating the Queen and threatening
mate in one so he has to defend against
the threat right he can't just do
nothing
Bishop f6 so far by the way this is
still theory we're following the theory
here okay so there are games has been
played like this now he goes h4
I which what I'm sorry and now my
opponent makes an inaccuracy he goes
King h7 he wasn't so familiar with this
line and he played this move King H I'm
thinking okay it looks great in accuracy
the best move here is h6 you're supposed
to play h6 first kick the knight back
and then play King g7 only then but he
didn't know this detail and now he
played he should have played h6 okay
aged six here and then he goes King g7
this position is more or less equal okay
I had some analysis I was gonna play but
it's more or less ago but he went here
and now it's your turn to find how to
take advantage of this inaccuracy why
you think this is just so important for
black to play h6 first and then play
this
excellent excellent
efore now the threat is a 595 he has to
react so he takes
right wait don't rush don't rush which
one which night this this one night see
for you could play that but I take you
and then I take on b2 so I think a lot
of your puns okay so you cannot do that
right away okay couldn't do that but
again in this default punished loose you
know and I don't know if you really want
to lose that pun very nice Castle
queenside energetically okay playing
very energetically now now I'm gonna get
the palm back only for no problem but
let me cancel first because now he
cannot really take this with a queen
because rook takes and you cannot move
the bishop because f7 pawn is very weak
he's under lots of pressure now so he
goes here
96 activating his knight and putting
pressure on d4 question is what should I
do
push push 95 push 95 not so clear that's
an interesting idea but better you could
do better than that what can you do here
huh okay yeah okay I guess we don't have
the letters on the sport okay so we go
Bishop we're here
no no but here takes little more a
little more
need a move that's the move you were
close
put the bishop on c4 because now you're
threatening very strong move you have
threatened to take it okay
see he didn't play h6 damn now he
doesn't have time to do it temples here
tempo sir must remember chess it's all
about temples so he was queen d6 now
he's in big trouble so he's offering me
the exchange of the Queen's because he
is afraid of getting me that Knight
takes f7 Queen h6 check it very well
turn into a checkmate so what to do now
don't rush you don't necessarily have to
reject right away the exchange of the
Queen's you must calculate yeah what's
gonna happen we need three then it takes
on d4 bishop before and take the Queen
okay what is the follow-up though
Knight takes f7 Knight takes f7 now
equal puns I'm attacking the rook on h8
I'm attacking the pawn on d6 so I got in
4th gear you're trying to made him howl
okay you still want to try this all
right let me see what's going on tix
temples temples Julian Julian temples
temples take your Bishop don't wanna
just play with the idea that you want to
mate and make it worse okay
okay Queenie - you don't have much
threats there it's not so clear anyway
okay you agree okay so take take now we
take now what is he gonna do we got a
[ __ ] right so he goes here Bishop g4
he's trying to get active activating his
Bishop and attack in my rook to be
honest from the first glance it doesn't
look that bad the position because two
bishops
some activities here it doesn't look
that bad here to be honest but it's
still pawns are hanging my rook is
hanging now what do I do
look D to hook up okay protect
everything Luke is still under attack
don't forget that so it goes Rock f8
attacking my knight Knight XD six he
takes my pawn and now what do I do
think that 926 is a strength guarding 8
and see 8 squares making those looks
look passive do you want to move the
knight from - no no don't move anything
get just try to see if we can take
something absolutely Knight take C 2 X
e4 and now the night is protecting the
other night
and the knight on the 6 is doing a
fantastic job guarding the squares now
this a position where block is down upon
no compensation and I'm threatening to
take his bishop on f6 if I can win his
bishop then it's over ok so he cannot
afford to lose his bishop here so he
goes Bishop e5 as expected
creating a threat everytime opponent
makes him move first thing you have to
do is to think what is it trying to do
what is the idea behind his last move
his idea is to play Bishop f4 and pin my
rook and win exchange he wants to pin it
so what's the good move to play here
g3 weakening the f3 square
allowing Knight f3 Bishop ated f3
nothing really bad but not the best look
at your king
okay what takes you can this one but
takes Bishop takes I want to go there
anyway so if you put the pawn I'll
gladly take it first
King b1 prophylactic move move the King
away no pins to worry about okay I need
to consolidate the position because once
I consolidated slowly I can convert this
into a win so he was Bishop f5 Oh think
about it yeah you not you don't have to
call out a move so quickly
think about it he has two bishops of
course he has two bishops we can
eliminate one let's take it all right
now he takes back with a pawn because he
wants to keep the night in the middle of
the board keep the pressure now where do
we go with the night absolutely c5
because the threat is 97 also rook takes
d4 Bishop T for 96 check picking up the
bishop so you get two pieces for a rope
95 excellent move
now quit okay
Bishop check well let's
yeah well King is on the here King is on
light square so you cannot use your
Bishop to check me so so he goes here he
sees the problem so he goes here now
looks like wait a minute I have two
pieces hanging my night my Bishop lose
pieces but of course I saw this idea and
I prepare something against it
don't rush I don't want to exchange like
that no no don't weaken the King like
that no tink tink you need a good move
here good move absolutely 97 I say you
can have the bishop because I'm gonna
get yours okay and no opposite color
bishops to worry about right so he took
I take now his rook is under attack
so he goes here nom up upon better
position better pieces awkward rukon
before no compensation okay for the
sacrifice pawn so what do you do now
look ad one double it up and enter in
the endgame
rooks belong we're on the seventh okay
so that's what I'm doing I'm removing
his Knight
so I can put the roof on d7 and start
picking up those pants you know h7 b7
that's what I'm trying to do here so it
was 96 trying to hang on here but he
can't
rook because pin it and win it Knight f3
is simply coming back and you take my
night I take your rook losing exchange
ok those kind of pins very unpleasant
you never almost never want to get there
so now Knight move to what do we do on a
seventh especially we can do it with a
check right if he goes to back rank is
very bad so he went here
don't trust your H pawn is hanging HH a
your knight on e5 is hanging here
don't rush think your Knight is in the
center why do you want to go back on f3
unless you really have to then you do it
all night no that's what he's saying but
I don't like that move your deactivating
your strong piece you never want to do
that you want to keep it rook 1 to d5
what's an idea it's an idea well that's
the rule that did d5 it's it was a silly
the board in front of you see the
letters and numbers so those are the
squares okay so each square has a name
okay so it's D 5 V 5 so there are names
for each square root is already on D 1
quiet move quiet move but very strong
because I'm threatening nothing less
than a checkmate aha what is he gonna do
now how to stop against it so now my
opponent wait I think it was resigned
here if he takes the pawn let's
investigate see what's happening here
why is this losing why he decided to
resign this was a pretty short game
looks like check he goes here now check
where to go I'm going to also take this
piece so he has to go here and what is
the winning move now don't rush now
though I don't want you to rush
because if you take the rope I take your
rock you take this one I take this one's
kind of absolutely correct rook to e7
double attacking this and attacking this
because I don't want to deal with rookie
for so you could have said oh just take
the pawn
you're winning probably but guess what
still have to show the technique to win
this so don't take chances okay
you only have one pawn but this move
forces the resignation because you take
a piece and also his rook on h4 is
hanging so he cannot really do anything
- all right so he cannot really do too
much we're gonna be doing studies okay
and game studies okay so let me set up
the first study for you okay these are
very advanced but very very good studies
for you to to see will help you to
improve the endgame and calculations
okay even though we have a extra piece
there the bishop block actually is in
trouble here and he is actually losing
here well think about it you need to
have a planet yeah it's not just push
push and win it's not just that
I think here think about it no no no
rush no rush okay no rush yes
no no it's white white to play white to
play and win okay study composed in 1892
okay a hairy old study actually down
this is just a little bit simpler than
the other ones
yes King d5 draw sure King the five
draws Bishop h6 any five yeah but you
need to have a plan okay a5 Bishop f8 we
should see if I'll draw if a six bishops
if I draw immediately if my bishop comes
in stops upon it's over now what okay
when you have their plan yeah we should
be three draw my bishop comes in stops
you're a pawn as soon as I can stop it
you're a pawn it's a draw cannot do
anything about it
cannot
draw
I stopped you
yeah but how are you gonna win okay
eating e-force fainting repetition well
you can do worse than a draw here draw
you have in your pocket increment yes
where do you want to go oh here yeah but
see the pole the point is he comes here
and he stops are upon or the only way we
can win is if we can somehow shut down
this bishop okay okay but you're playing
this for white and you're trying to win
now that was suggested this should be a
draws immediately not so many pieces on
the board and since I shouldn't be that
difficult you know they're not so many
pieces here but tricky tricky
Bishop h6 pawn up this one
aha specified specify a g5 that g5 yeah
I see if we have this coordinates
okay now we have our coordinates so g5
sacrificing a pawn I captured it now I
want to go here and stop you from
pushing it perfect
bish page for now I want to go here stop
you what you gonna do
perfect
excellent that is the solution because
the bishop cannot reach here in time to
stop this pawn okay cannot do anything
all right
everybody understand this one let's do
it again first move King is a way it's
not in a square so cannot catch the pawn
by just getting closer okay so he needs
to go here if he takes for the King you
just push a six eight seven
let's take here game is so much
excellent okay so that's our first study
now second study very nice from one of
my favorite studies white to play white
to play and win and it may seem bit
strange because white has all this
pieces looks like why he cannot just win
this easily the problem is black has two
threats to push and to take there are
just two threats and what to do well
think you again you need to have a plan
now Kings he wanna lose this because he
had Bishop e2 he doesn't want to go in
front okay
doesn't want to do here so you go here
pan takes Knight Queen remember I have
two threats I'm going to push and I want
to Queen so this is the problem see one
Queen check take your knight in check
you just blocked it you gotta be careful
there it could lose rook e8 chick
alright Knight
I don't want to take because then you
have this check because actually when I
take I only have one threat now and now
I step away you win easily so it was
here no I'm not taking it
no King - he just takes he just takes on
d1
that's repetition it was like this or
they check here check here
this is the key moment right here that
you need to find the right move here
without this movie cannot win the game I
know the thread seems so strong and we
almost like as soon as we see him
queening we almost think ok it's over
but I need you to go a little bit more
okay you need to go a little bit more no
but then he checks he promotes and
checks and he takes your night it will
be a draw at least you need to be
creative here wrong see one check kink
a2 then I just you don't have threads
basically
now what can you do here you could do a
little worse
close yeah you're close guys there is
nothing for the four squares within hide
he's got it all right you got it
brilliant brilliant idea
now if it takes we just go check and go
King beat you okay now I go see one
check
huh
do you want
now if you go to the C file he's gonna
go to see a check and win so he's gonna
go here we should be to be careful its
inaccuracy he's escaping now if he
escapes it'll draw now we should be
three blunders check still mate see I
just want to make a draw here I just
want to make a draw but how how can you
win it see the problem is that still
mate here he wants to go Queen B - and
still meet you
so what you gonna do first here
look down at you two
what is your thread you got a create
thread right if you make a move there is
no thread then you trying to win I can
force the draw like this II still mate
here Julian just did that I told you the
thread is still mate but anyway what is
your thread have to be super fun let's
say I pass well no that's not going to
happen that's too long
h3g for yeah that's too long that's not
realistic here Oh pish pish on a
six-year wait Bishop's hit a gig with
Agilent again still mate
what move look what rookie - you say
rookie - cream b1 still still mate see
this freaking on the one it's not a good
square for you because too many still
mate ideas you gotta get him away from
there okay
with here oh it's not that easy let me
stop that first be careful now yeah be
careful you might get yourself in
trouble here check and take your look
not true who should be playing for a
drawn-out you nuts
Queen cannot underestimate the Queen
yeah this could be tricky now probably
still make a draw but you have an idea
or just a check but you don't have a
winning idea okay but you got the right
answer correct if you go see two rooks
see it we see that right check and take
so he has to go here and the winning
move is
he is in the net he is in the mating net
now Queen to d2 careful yeah I can
sacrifice my queen also to force a draw
Oh
okay and now you're threatening check
mate perfect job the king is in the
mating net and the only way to get rid
of it he has to be able to go to d1 okay
the only way to get out of it has to go
to d1 and if it goes to d1 look after
one chip it's not still made anymore
we broke the steel maybe because it's
got the square available to go to so no
still made very important ok tricky one
let's do it again very tricky one
why to play and win here look the a
check this is losing we should be too
excellent I see three brilliant
this was a difficult there we were a
little bit stuck at this point so many
different suggestions but all of them
lead to a draw at least check if it goes
to see to Roxy a check and if he goes
here and checkmate
excellent job okay excellent white to
play and win okay
the reason you can win this because the
position of the black king is very very
awkward okay very very awkward so what
can we do here to try to win this we
have an excellent idea
no no no then he goes bishop c8 no but
if your King wasn't there what would you
do if your say your key Hosanna G file
what would you do
checkmate right maybe that's a big
difference one will win one will not win
it's that important one will win another
one will not win Bishop takes g8 no
enjoy data at that point well yeah but
that's he'll see the threat yeah yes
indeed you don't see it now I don't want
to reveal yet now he threatened made
correct the only way for him not to get
made it has to play the move Bishop g8
has to okay and now you want to threaten
a checkmate from f8 but you still have
to keep him always pinned okay always
pinned you understand beautiful now
hitting checkmate he has to go here
otherwise he's getting checked me did
nothing he can do to get out of from
this box you know he really box them in
I know this rook so he goes here and now
imagine he had the King on g3 here it
would have blocked something it would
have black a move here that you have the
winning move in fact
correct setting up checkmate and setting
up the whole point is anytime he moves
this beep on any time you move your
queen is gonna move the beep on but here
if he moves the beep on you go down here
and say checkmate you see the point as
soon as he plays b.push you have to have
a mate if you don't have a maid you
missed it but here you got it see if you
had a king on g3 here you could not play
Queen h3 that's why the difference is
big here
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]